[Music]
ted comes out on DVD tomorrow this movie
has not just been successful it's been
spectacularly successful half a billion
dollars this movie has me yeah yeah
that's it that's that's crazy is there a
TV is there a blu-ray in that cuz I
haven't gotten mine yet and maybe I can
take that with me one yeah you can have
this one you know it's yes blue right in
here one are you there that's your happy
that's the only reason you came I was
thinking today cut are we gonna get free
copies I haven't gotten one and look at
this I'm this is me being completely
serious I'm not even joking no you're
gonna sit down tonight and watch it well
I've seen it a hundred times my last
thing I want to do is watch it no I want
to say I want to put it on the shelf you
know next to the vow and see how neat
and tidy it looks you can have the
cardboard cover too thank you you you
had a very good song in in the movie our
opening title every everybody needs a
best friend and there's a possibility
that that could be an oscar-nominated
song that that is our yeah VFX our
special effects team and and the song or
are really the only two points of
likelihood that a movie like Ted has to
be nominated for an Oscar movies like
Ted as you may know don't get nominated
for Best Picture
but yeah it's at Norah Jones sang it
it's and yeah we think we have a shot
we'll see you know that'd be fantastic
use about time something went your way I
love this this is going to be a big
Christmas toy this year you can buy the
the bear you can buy Ted but my favorite
thing is I noticed there's this tag on
it
rated R right it's so
I just love a child cuddling up to a
rated or teddy bear and then it just
says you yeah he or he talking bear it
says things and I just had never thought
we'd live in a world where think oh no
not for me
yeah rated R yeah for you I really I
just want this you can take that I have
Wow
this shows turning out amazingly well
how do I make it talk you got to squeeze
the paw Oh nothing's happening well well
most of the others work the other part
the other part
no no they gave you a bum bear yeah what
terrible advertising
I just there's no batteries in it
imagine it you know why don't you tell
us what it says you were sure yeah yeah
to the bear and then you say right it
says when you hear the sound of fun that
don't you'll get through scared just
grab your Thunder buddy and say these
magic words you Thunder you can Mike you
can't get me [ __ ] you afraid
[Applause]
and authors the Oscars got to you can I
say the f-word I'm trying
the person that does our bleeping is
very yes I'm gonna save the mother who
does your bleep we fired that guy a long
time ago we have a deleted scene this is
a song that's one yeah this is a scene
that you I guess cut out of the movie
yeah if it wasn't good enough because it
wasn't good now now we get to do them
they get to show in here now it's a
street because that's what Conan is that
what Conan's all about hey Tay can I
tell you something nobody knows my mom
and dad took me to the park for a picnic
and they have your stuff on there when
nobody was looking you pooped in my hand
and threw it at a duck does that mean a
[Music]
[Applause]
giant wave of laughter from this crowd
till tonight
just me that we we made the right choice
this is a test crowd just to make sure
and you should feel good now I feel like
a hundred bucks yeah